[Music]
to be honest with you I'm on his side
because as I said if I am in control of
everything Our Lives depend on me
carrying your shoulders well just out of
curiosity but that's only when they're
carrying the child oh that that wasn't
even if someone is carrying their child
that's when they've got 100 payment of
everything and you can't say [ __ ]
even if you're even if the woman hold on
even if the woman is carrying the child
the responsibility hasn't changed
because the woman's carrying the child
no but the mom's got all the
responsibility she's inside with the U
would you not say that like it's okay so
people sit there in this modern in age
we say we women go out to work as well
in relationships as it should be right
and then but then it should also be 50
50 at home as well if if it's 50 50
outside of the home as in we're both
earning money we're both putting in
we're both working five six days a week
all right it doesn't matter who's
earning more we're both putting in that
amount wow
let me let me land
um it doesn't matter we're both putting
in nine to fives all right and then
we're both coming home
work there should get split at 50 50 as
well
if I do the laundry this week that
should be the way because if not if a
woman's going out it's working the same
amount of days as you oh yeah we
understand what you're saying yeah okay
you work and he works you understand you
said it like five different ways yeah at
the end of the day that's your choice if
you are the type of woman that boom okay
I want 50 50. like this young lady said
50 50. cool that's the life you chose
then of course boom you're 50 50 bro so
obviously you got 50 of the
responsibility but we're not talking
about that we're talking about I'm a
princess bro thank you that's not that
that doesn't make sense
you're King Rich nobody said yeah do you
know what was funny about these
conversations yeah like we'll be talking
and making like straight facts and
sticking to a straight topic and then
what I noticed with a lot of women is
that they will add in extras so adding
extras that came out of nowhere like you
actually said that like nobody added
those ages is that you you know what I'm
saying everything I've said has been
very straightforward and in my opinion
this is where a lot of the problems
between men and women come from that you
know you a lot of men find it hard to
express what we're saying to women
because women will dislike bring in
extra intangibles out of nowhere you can
really you need to you you need to stay
on topic thank you all right can I break
your brain for a second yeah
let me move on to the I just wanna
quickly yeah okay so whenever you talk
about if I'm paying 100 it's I it's what
I say I wanted to ask why is it that
with with if if you're paying more as in
there's a power thing that happens with
men or what I'm seeing in this room
already where there's a sense of if it's
not 50 50 then it's I what I say and
it's straight away starts to come across
as now you are my controller do you get
it what is it that comes with the power
what is that that chest that comes with
the more I put in my chest must be up
here you better listen to me why can't
it be because he's doing 100 but I love
you baby all right I'm asking what is
the end of the day at the end of the day
if I'm financing your life bro if I'm
putting the roof over your head and I'm
supplying the food that we eat bro like
yeah a certain level of responsibility
comes just like you said that if it if
it all messes up here it's on me no
one's gonna look to you your parents
ain't gonna look to you my parents ain't
gonna look to you yeah they're gonna
look at me like you [ __ ] up yeah you
know what I'm saying so with that
responsibility comes Authority as well
just the same way is when you have
children you look after the children the
man and the woman you have authority
over there I'm not saying women are
children but it's the same Lord I was
gonna say it's coming across a little
bit parental you can't just do this and
did it you better listen to what I say
there's a parental side that comes to it
and traditional my parents pay for every
paid for every thing when I was a kid
but I just feel like even if my man is
doing 100 we are here now we are here
with you're not my parent you're not now
gonna start telling me what to do
because you're putting in one hand then
that means we can sit down and liaise
because that means you should be 50. so
you you think that what you're putting
in should be directly proportional to
how you deal with your partner that asks
you something but that's how women treat
men though
you say 50 years you say 50 50 yeah does
that mean 50 50 when someone jumps in
the yard and you're just gonna accept us
is it 50 50 then well if you're sleeping
at night yeah yeah and then and then um
someone jumps in the yard the kind of
woman I am yes I'm fighting with you no
no no no fighting with you 50 50 doesn't
mean he's he says babe listen I want you
to go and check that what's going on
downstairs and he sends you downstairs
last time was my turn this time is your
turn
I just want to understand first of all
I've heard all of you talk and I'm
starting to understand that
why would you get in a relationship if
you don't agree in the first place I'm
seeing that you guys are saying there's
a lot of oh if you don't do this you're
gonna fight go back and forth
like a relationship is a like
pre-contract before you go into it you
sit and say are you good with this the
other person says no I'm not and then
you kind of go back and forth before you
then get in a relationship nowadays A
lot of people want to jump into a
relationship and then you get upset when
things aren't working for you right and
then you start looking elsewhere that's
when cheating starts that's when you
start doing stupid things right and now
the society we're just constantly
fighting for stupid things if I don't
like being with you because you're not
meeting my terms then I'll walk away we
have we this time modern women I hate
that right it used to be something and
like my grandparents or my grandma in
that sense I would call myself a modern
woman but the one woman that my
grandmother wanted me to be back then
they didn't my grandma got married to my
grandfather he was this growing Big Oil
guy right
and she didn't work for a while because
she had everything she wanted she had
all her kids in different countries all
that kind of stuff but she brought up
her daughters my mother in a way that
she had all the education the best
education she could have
um to be a strong woman with will but
still respect her husband and all the
men in her family and that is a modern
woman that's what my grandmother wanted
her and her children to be right
nowadays women we come up thinking we
have something we have money we have our
own houses and cars whatever that is so
we want men to be either giving us way
more than we have right or giving having
unexpected realities and we now tagged
it as a mother Modern Woman
I'm a modern woman I have I guess
everything I think I want right and now
my mister has seen that I see him on a
certain level
he I understand babe do you bring this
to the table I want you to bring this I
want you to bring that as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible